former first lady michelle obama stopped
by the uh ellen degeneres show today and
offered to help ellen find a new hobby
now that her daytime talk show is ending
after 19 seasons on may 26th yeah this
is something i never thought uh we'd see
just take a look at what happened when
the pair attended an art class and
attempted to paint a nude model take it
take it away ladies
hey everybody sorry we're late
come on in oh my gosh
oh my god
erin come on in hi erin this is aaron
everyone
hi erin hi erin hi erin
[Music]
today we are going to be working on the
human physique yes we are so you want to
pay attention to the curves of the
muscles
okay proportions i need a bigger thumb
i don't know where to start with this
the human body is generally eight heads
tall so you start with the head or
another area
michelle it's like you always say when
they hang low you paint high
i don't say that yes you've always said
it
you said when they hang low we paint
them for what i said so work with
breaking down the human body into simple
shapes
your shoulder is a circle
oh my gosh
[Music]
i think i'm really a natural at this